[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7 8 sociétés sur tv soixante
dix huit émissions qui aborde
l'actualité à travers le prisme du
documentaire thématique de ce mois ci
cité ils oeuvrent au quotidien ou
comment agir pour faire émerger les
talents dans les quartiers les plus en
difficulté à des invités autour de cette
table pour parler de cette thématique
mustapha larfaoui ancien président du
club de football de trappes notamment
bonsoir soins à vos côtés jean jemaa
cofondateur producteurs de la troupe de
danse black blanc beur sur saint quentin
en yvelines bonsoir également algernon
jany bonsoir et bienvenue responsable du
bureau positif planète dans les yvelines
vous êtes installés sur trappe depuis
peu positif planète entreprendre en
banlieue font des apparats jacques
attali on va en parler tout à l'heure et
puis laurent dumas bonsoir peut-être
directeur à la solidarité pour
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pour le moment vous allez
découvrir nous allons découvrir ce
documentaire comme hôte du réalisateur
est dit habib sy comme mode c'est le nom
d'un groupe pionnier du reggae
réunionnais les membres sont originaires
du chaudron la première cité hlm à la
réunion et ce sont les émeutes violentes
en février 91 qui les ont poussés comme
ils le disent à canaliser leurs messages
par la musique comme vote ni plus ni
moins une co production tv 78 calme
semble revenu ce matin mais que de
nouveaux affrontements
la nuit dernière ont fait huit morts
pour rétablir le dialogue entre humains
et de tanger
enfin il ya les véritables causes
jauzion c'est une commission clé tout ce
qui à mon sens aux mots vision moins
tout ce qui était négatif nous mon but
ce qui transforme alliant positif sa
force positif écoutez nous donnerait des
sites
nataf et se passe devant nous que nous
vois que tout le monde ferme les jeux
nous l'a choisi sa musique la musique
c'est un choix si nos tv travail n'était
pas l'ironie travail voire qu'exor et
auchan
[Musique]
voilà des gameblogueurs qu'on m'avait
pas dit si tu avais fait entrer
techniquement mais nouveau la
revendication d'égalité
[Musique]
l'intrigué cité
de retour sur le plateau de tv soixante
dix huit pour la seconde partie de ce
sept huit sociétés avec nos invités nous
allons donc parler de ces actions menées
au quotidien pour aider les populations
des quartiers des cités est les plus en
difficulté bonsoir à nouveau à mustapha
larbaoui l'ancien président du club de
football de trappage angie mad
confondateur producteurs de la troupe de
danse black blanc beur à gerber jany
également responsable du bureau positive
planète entreprendre en banlieue et puis
laurent dumas directeur à la solidarité
à l'agglomération de saint quentin
on vient donc de suivre le documentaire
sur ce groupe né au coeur d'une cité le
chaudron à la réunion un exemple une
fois de plus que le talent existe dans
ces quartiers en difficulté mais surtout
qu'il est possible de s'exprimer
autrement que par la violence il y à
d'autres moyens se rebeller en quelque
sorte je me tourne vers vous deux safa
larbaoui les gens que j'aime had que ce
soit par le sport ou encore par la danse
les jeunes qui sont inscrits et qui sont
encore aujourd'hui inscrits dans vos
structures preuve qui prouve par donc
ils peuvent agir pour montrer leur leur
identité s'exprimer il ya aussi une
prise en main individuel pour s'exprimer
autrement pas que par la violence en
fait en quelque sorte c'était le message
véhiculé dans le documentaire qu'on a vu
sa fin alors que ce soit par le sport
que ce soit par la culture en
l'occurrence ce sont des vecteurs voir
des prétextes
donc on utilise pour faire passer des
messages on parle souvent de messages ou
2 ou de valeur on l'a vu dans leur
partager et on en parle en réalité ce
type de solutions on a parlé des
violences de 91
donc ça fait si je peux éviter bien ça
fait quelque chose comme 26 ans
en réalité on parle de solutions 10 à 26
ans mais les solutions on en parlait
déjà il ya 40 ans il ya quarante ans
déjà dans ce type de structure dans ce
type de territoire pour ça comme on veut
banlieues sensibles quartiers sensibles
comme on voudra prenons les mots qu'on
veut mais il ya il ya des choses à faire
en rapport avec la promiscuité d'une
part en rapport avec l'idée que l'on a
on a des choses à transmettre et que le
sport on va dire le loisir en général
sauf si li té consomme hâtif le loisir
est un formidable vecteur pour faire
pour émanciper
on va dire les individus mais on est en
train de parler de ces sujets là et
c'est de plus en plus récurrents
maintenant le face à des violences il y
en a toujours eu mais de plus en plus
violentes et on a le sentiment de
faudrait trouver des solutions d'un coup
de baguette magique dirait ton mais en
réalité les solutions existaient on les
a vus dans dans ce reportage
ça fait partie de l'arsenal de ce qu'on
peu de ce qu'on peut utiliser je parle
on parle du sport et de la culture mais
il ya 40 ans je suis très content d'être
à côté de de gens se soient pas pouvoir
le dire et le redire et le redire encore
il ya 30 ans c'est des choses que moi
j'ai apprise par les gens comme jean
jemal ou mouloud violain qui déjà à
l'époque avait fait passer l'idée selon
laquelle les activités devaient pas être
seulement 2 on va dire de canaliser
parce qu'il n'ya pas à canaliser les
gens il ya les faire émerger
il n'y a pas non plus à l'aise allez on
va dire à les animer ou allez vous faire
en sorte qu'ils passent un bon moment
alors que derrière passer du temps elle
a un travail qui est mené derrière et
justement c'était jean dauger c'était
des gens qui avaient des actions réelles
juste juste une d'une phrase moi je me
souviens que dans les banlieues qu'il
m'arrivait de rencontrer des gens qui
avaient donc on va dire sociologiquement
csp plus plus plus et j'ai l'impression
qu'ils avaient cassé du caillou pendant
leurs vacances comme moi j'étais dans le
loisir et quand je dis casser du camion
a été c'est parce qu il avait réaménagé
des structures des châteaux de vieille
église et au travers des activités
culturelles
il y avait quelque chose qui se passait
mais c'est elle et on va dire les
versailles et nous dans nos banlieues
on s'amusait on fait en sorte qu'on
s'amuse et on le disait déjà à l'époque
en tous les cas moi c'est comme ça que
j'ai compris et aujourd'hui ce qu'on
fait avec le foot par exemple est un
prétexte ou pharma citoyens mais aussi
votre association d'associations par
l'expérience du talent et au théâtre
récemment est allé voir le musée de la
sécurité sociale récemment nos enfants
il nous quand on les aime
nous suivent et quand on leur dit des
choses ils ne comprennent très vite très
bien faut juste qu'on fasse des choses
qui ont du sens pardon jemal justement
dans les années 80 vous avez fondé cette
compagnie black blanc beur avec une
chorégraphe christine coudun vous avez
justement tout de suite compris que au
delà du fait d'occuper le temps parce
que c'est pas ça dont on parle c'est
aussi de montrer que devrait y avait du
talent il y avait des choses qui
pouvaient émerger il y avait des
vocations qui pouvait se créer aussi et
il y avait des choses à exprimer
et c'est ce que vous avez fait que black
blanc beur 4 et faire émerger des
talents passés en passant parce qu en
fait l'idée est simple c'est surtout de
se mettre dedans se mettre dans un
processus on se confronte à une réalité
à une pratique que ce soit l'arrêt
d'ailleurs l'emploi plutôt l'art que la
culture parce qu'il culture une notion
beaucoup plus là qui peut être aussi une
notion produite par l'institution qui
est complètement nécessaire mais là
c'est la pratique c'est l'artisan c'est
celui qui s'y colle et on s'est dit que
ce soit dans ce domaine dans d'autres
faut s'y coller la deuxième il faut
avoir un objectif à atteindre un désir
il faut construire un désir pour avoir
le moteur qui convient et nous sommes
mis en rupture à cette époque là je
crois que c'est encore une idée qui est
intéressante à débattre on s'est mis en
rupture de moins que le secteur éducatif
avec le secteur scolaire non pas en le
d'aignan mais en apportant un regard
complètement différent où on se mettait
pas en domination dans les connaissances
qu on transmettait et où on se
confrontaient nous-mêmes ès qualité
puisque c'était pas nos métiers au
départ christian était danseuse à l'est
devenu chorégraphe s'y est formée moi je
sais pas non plus si l'on n'est pas
seulement
mais c'est pas pour dire ça c'est pour
dire qu'à un moment donné tout le monde
a dû être autre chose autrement et que
cette manière d'avoir à vivre ensemble
dans un processus actif à mon avis et
c'est cela qui est intéressant parce que
c'est ce qui permet à chacun de produire
pour lui même
certes une identité mais surtout un
ancrage une reconnaissance ci a minima
ça sert aux autres habitants à avoir
leurs enfants les enfants de leurs
voisins autrement avec un autre regard
c'est déjà très réussi mais ça peut
aller beaucoup plus loin que ça tient
que ça peut offrir une capacité à
construire un libre arbitre
une certaine idée de la liberté qui à
mon avis est encore un combat largement
à menu et tout ça se fait aussi avec
l'intervention des pouvoirs publics
parce qu'on parle naturellement vous
mesurez d'ultimes est pris en main moi
j'ai créé black blanc beur en face il y
avait pas
lancement de la ville nouvelle et des
moyens exceptionnels à saint quentin
comme ailleurs non on a fait ça dont on
fait autre chose
il est certain que ce type
d'expérimentation c'est un véritable
investissement
et c'était pas un investissement pour
occuper le temps des gens qui nous font
peur ça c'est sûr il m'a justement
puisqu'on parle du travail des pouvoirs
publics et il ya cette intervention vous
mener le travail que vous menez avec les
associations dans le cadre
plus largement on parle de politique de
la ville véritablement alors la
politique de la ville elle se déploie
principalement à partir d'un contrat qui
est signée entre 32 partenaires donc le
contrat de ville intercommunal de saint
quentin 32 signataires on trouve bien
sûr l'état la caisse des dépôts les
communes gagne évidemment on trouve
également 14 organismes de hlm donc
c'est la première fois que nous avons
réussi à réunir tous les bailleurs
sociaux du territoire autour d'un même
projet partagé
alors concernant les projets des
initiatives qui sont lancés sur le
territoire depuis maintenant quelques
temps
l'objectif de l'agglomération et bien
sûr d'accompagner ces initiatives c'est
ses projets dans un cadre qui est celui
je le disais tout à l'heure du conte
traduit donc un cadre structuré partager
avec des objectifs qui sont partagés
entre ses différents partenaires
à partir de ces objets qui vous avez des
plans d'action et donc vous avez des
porteurs de projets qui viennent qui
sollicitent soit l'agglomération soit
les communes soit l'état soit les trois
dans certains cas et c'est ensuite à
chacun de ses partenaires d'accompagner
ces initiatives pour autant qu'elles
répondent aux objectifs qui ont été
déterminés alors c'est le cas bien
évidemment pour pour black blanc beur ou
pour les clubs de sport puisque on
citait vous parliez de la caisse qui a
la compétence première cela dit la
compétence politique de la ville est une
compétence obligatoire de
l'agglomération présent qu'à ce titre à
sous et c'est vrai qu'on peut se
permettre
j'allais dire d'avoir un champ
d'intervention extrêmement large
pluridisciplinaire et aujourd'hui on
peut pas dire que pour certains porteurs
de projets tout le monde peut trouver sa
place dans le contrat de ville à partir
du moment où on a comme priorité de
favoriser j'allais dire l'épanouissement
la construction de deux projets de sens
donner du sens en fait à sa vie parce
que c'est quand même la finalité
poursuivie par l'ensemble de nos actions
et puis s'inscrire dans un projet de vie
avec des objectifs donc si qu'un travail
de long terme a bien évidemment très
mobilisateur et on a aujourd'hui près
d'une quarantaine d'associations qui
sont accompagnés par par l'agglomération
c'est un travail qui est fait pour
l'avenir vous accompagner ces jeunes en
vous disant justement ils peuvent aussi
du coup se canaliser trouver des
vocations à prendre aussi ce que c'est
la citoyenneté par exemple c'est ce que
vous faites avec pharma citoyens aussi
par exemple un notamment ouais alors moi
ce que j'aime c'est beaucoup qu'à voir
ce type de propos autour de cette table
mais c'est surtout d'avoir l'impact sur
les jeunes dont on parle est souvent
c'est pas trop des discours qui les
acquis dont ils ont envie mais ce sont
des actes ce sont des réalités voire
même de deux des choses très simples par
exemple quand on explique à nos enfants
que le plus important dans le foot mais
on pourrait dire dans alors je vais
reprendre les notions de mon professeur
l'art en général mais on parlait de la
culture tout à l'heure ça soit le
théâtre ou le foot l'entraînement
l'entraînement l'entraînement et c'est
là qu'on y apprend tout comme l'école
l'école l'école et donc il ya en
permanence des choses simples à
expliquer et à faire en sorte que les
messages passent facilement pour les
enfants moi j'ai pour habitude de dire
que quand je regarde un un reportage
alors pardon c'est une vraiment pour le
coup c'est une image ne le prenez pas
mal mais c'est l'idée selon laquelle
quand on regarde des petits lionceaux de
petits bébés animaux ils s'amusent en
restant dans l'impression qu'ils sont en
train de l'apprendre à ce comment
s'amuser mais c'est en réalité comment
on apprend à chasser comment on apprend
à être dans la nature comment on arrive
à ce bien là c'est pareil on joue on
s'amuse on fait du loisir on n'oublie
jamais qui a une il ya une notion
éducative derrière et quand je parlais
tout à l'heure de d'éléments simples
c'est de la même façon que quand on
était là la sécurité sociale
on a toujours tout on m'a demandé ce que
je foutais à la sécurité sociale avec
des gamins de 10 ans parce qu'il n'y a
aucun rapport entre le foot et le musée
de la sécu bassi parce que le foot c'est
un sport collectif il ya des sports
individuels mais le sport individuel on
peut prendre sa mutuelle tout seul et le
sport collectif c'est je passe la balle
je donne la balle je verse à la sécu je
reçois de la sécu donc il ya des choses
simples a expliqué on a besoin d'avoir
de grands discours parce qu'on a besoin
d'établir des schémas directionnelle on
a besoin de porter des politiques de la
ville avec de grands discours et un élan
de notre part mais nos mômes ils veulent
des choses simples parce qu'ils les
comprennent aussi simplement que ça et
on parle souvent d'autorité également
moi j'ai le club de foot on y était
pendant 14 ans c'est pas un souci
l'autorité et l'autoritarisme
oui mais quand c'est dans le respect
quand c'est dans l'explication quand
c'est tout simplement dans l'amour dans
l'affect
il se passe des choses qui sont pour le
coup j'ai un simple et pour le coup un
mot important a été prononcé par jean et
je le reprendrais aussi c'est cette idée
de reconnaissance de respect on peut
faire plein de choses
après il n'ya pas que de mauvaises
choses dans ces banlieues dans ces
quartiers sensibles
j'y suis né
grandi il ya des gens qui y vivent je
suis sur le territoire attrapent souvent
il ya des choses magnifiques
la plupart le sont on parle souvent de
violences moi je dis qu'on devrait
mériter pour certains le prix nobel de
la paix et non pas de la violence pour
c'est pour beaucoup
vous avez mentionné trappe on va parler
d eux aussi des nous préciser que la
politique de la ville s'inscrit dans
l'ensemble des communes de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et ensuite on va parler aussi
du travail que vous menez avec positif
planète et compte n'est plus dans la
partie entrepreneuriat là on est sur
quelque chose d'un peu différent que le
domaine associatif dont on parlait tout
à l'heure
juste pour préciser cette politique de
la ville touche toutes les communes les
quartiers sont ciblés aussi sur
l'intervention comment cela se passe
cette commune donc 30 près de 35000
habitants sur les 230 mille habitants de
l'agglomération
donc c'est quand même à près d'un
habitant sur sept
donc c'est une politique qui est assez
assez ambitieuses sur laquelle mobilise
près de près d'un million d'euros la
communauté d'agglomération ce sont les
quarante acteurs associatifs que je
mentionnais tout à l'heure avec
néanmoins une difficulté aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on est un territoire multiples
donc il faut organiser la multitude
favoriser les coopérations entre acteurs
associatifs dans un univers qui est
souvent très très cloisonné alors c'est
pas simplement pour le monde associatif
on est dans une société très très
cloisonné donc aujourd'hui c'est comment
organiser et préserver cette multitude
qui aussi l'expression de la diversité
mais qui est aussi et c'est peut-être
que revers de la médaille
celui du fractionnement des divisions et
c'est là
j'allais dire aujourd'hui l'enjeu
comment faire ensemble
comment développer les coopérations le
vivre ensemble et le travail en commun
le travail de positif planète à présent
alors on est loin du domaine artistique
et sportif cette fois ci concrètement
comment vous travaillez comme on vous
agissait alors depuis tous derrière jean
j'entends le discours de tout le monde
et c'est vrai qu'on a je pense un mot en
commun ses talents et aujourd'hui nous
notre travail c'est de mettre en avant
ses talents mais par l'entrepreneuriat
donc c'est vrai que positifs permettent
on intervient son accompagnement la
création d'entreprises donc on
accompagne les porteurs de projets qui
sont issus des quartiers dans tout le
parcours d'accompagnement donc on part
du stade de l'idée et on travaille avec
eux l'étude de marché les prévisions
financières
le financement jusqu'à l'immatriculation
et on fait un suivi avec eux jusqu'à
trois ans après la création et
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est important
de mettre en avant ses quartiers parce
que sur ces quartiers là il ya un réel
potentiel et surtout nous nos
implantations elles sont faites de
manière très stratégique c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on va dire que le nom
c'est positif planète entreprendre en
banlieue puisque notre travail de
terrain est vraiment axé sur le sur ces
cas sont ces quartiers parce que c'est
public aujourd'hui qui sont les plus
éloignés de l'emploi
c'est le public qui on a constaté qu'ils
sont les où les plus oubliées et pour
pouvoir les sensibiliser il faut qu'on
soit au quotidien avec eux on va dire
que notre travail va pas être n'est pas
forcément facile tous les jours puisque
l'accès de sensibilisation n'est pas
immédiat mais au moins nous identifie et
à travers cette identification à un
moment donné ils vont travailler la
réfection de la création d'entreprise en
alternative à l'emploi et c'est vraiment
aujourd'hui le message qu'on veut faire
passer les réalisations concrètes
peut-être qu'ils ont été mené jusqu'à
présent et un bureau qui vient d'ouvrir
la sur le secteur de saint quentin en
yvelines mais positif planète existe
déjà dans d'autres secteurs
exactement donc en fait positionne être
la première antenne a ouvert fin 2012
sur fois ci aujourd'hui on est à un peu
plus de 200 créations
et un peu plus de 600 personnes
accompagnés tout au long de ces années
et c'est vrai que c'est des cons à dire
c'est les créations concrètes pour nous
parce qu'on a un taux de pérennité de
67% et c'est ça qui est le plus
important
on cherche vraiment à travailler sur le
qualitatif et non sur le quantitatif
aujourd'hui on passe du temps à
accompagner nos porteurs de projets on a
vraiment une phase de diagnostic qui est
importante pour nous et c'est à travers
ce diagnostic on va retravailler les
différentes étapes avec les porteurs de
projets je vous donne l'exemple d'un
porteur de projet qui est venu
dernièrement dans mon bureau qui voulait
faire une formation de vtc chose que
tout le monde fait à l'heure actuelle
mais en discutant avec lui on était dans
les changes il s'est un peu plus ouvert
et il m'a dit moi ça fait 20 ans que je
suis dans la coiffure afro et c'est ce
que je voulais faire mais mon projet n'a
pas abouti il a voulu acheter quelque
chose à lille et son projet n'a pas la
boutique du coup bah il est rester sur
cet échec là et s'est tourné vers autre
chose et aujourd'hui on est en train de
travailler sur l'achat d'un fonds de
commerce à paris dans la coiffure afro
parce que il est né avec ça il a
travaillé avec ça maintenant cet échec
l'a un peu renfermé sur lui-même mais à
travers le travail qu'on a fait ensemble
sur les différents rendez-vous qu'on a
eues aujourd'hui on en arrive à faire
aboutir son projet de manière plus
concrète même le travail laurent dumas
qui est menée par l'association par
positive planète c'est aussi quelque
chose que vous regardez vous intervenez
avec l'agglomération de saint quentin
aussi est-ce que ça s'inscrit dans le
cadre de leurs ondes un boulet un volet
développement économique effectivement
puisque le contrat d'huile est organisé
en trois volets cohésion sociale
développement économique et rénovation
urbaine qui va concerner principalement
trappe et dans une moindre mesure la
verrière plaisir sur le volet
développement économique donc vous avez
un outil le ski cubain qui aujourd'hui
une maison de l'entreprise qui est
ouverte à tous à tous les créateurs
donc ça c'est important quel que soit le
niveau d'avancement de leur projet de
création avec la possibilité d'avoir un
accompagnement adapté et en soutien pour
l'accompagnement dans la durée on a des
opérateurs associatifs qui interviennent
ensuite pour compléter cette offre de
services sur sur le territoire
évidemment la difficulté là aussi c'est
faire connaître
cette offre de services à évoquer tout à
l'heure la la multitude
aujourd'hui on le voit bien que ce soit
dans le domaine de l'emploi ou de la
santé on a des habitants qui sont perdus
1 face à cette multitude donc vous avez
des lieux ressources sur le territoire
qui permettent de j'allais dire
d'accéder en fait à la connaissance à
connaître l'ensemble des des réponses
qui peuvent être apportées sur le
territoire donc je pense tout à l'heure
j'évoquais tout à l'heure le ski cube
on a également l'institut de promotion
de la santé pour vous avez des points
services aux particuliers également qui
sont ancrées dans les quartiers et qui
peuvent régler tous les litiges de la
vie quotidienne
la maison de justice et du droit
également qui pour répondre à toutes les
questions juridiques
donc aujourd'hui cette offre de services
elle est réelle elle est multiple mais
elle est encore assez peu connu en tout
cas insuffisamment connue des publics
pour lesquels nous travaillons
principalement qui sont des quartiers
les publics pardon d'un de la politique
de la ville sur l'évaluation sur les
résultats qui sont obtenues rayonnait
alors sur l'évaluation donc l'année 2018
sera l'année de l'évaluation à
mi-parcours du contrat de ville qui a
été signé à la fin de l'année 2015 2020
voilà donc l'objectif de cette
évaluation c'est de connaître de mener
une étude d'impact a donc de savoir en
quoi la politique et de la villette
impactante pour les habitants des
quartiers dans les quartiers de la
politique de la ville on fera un bilan
voir venir bilan un bilan d'étape ici
sur le plateau jean dauger mahb lorsque
vous avez fondé black blanc beur on peut
dire qu'il y avait assez peu de choses
qui s'adressait à ses jeunes pour le
canaliser pour rôle de la de les
canaliser
s'intéresser à eux tout simplement oui
des premiers dispositifs qui vont donner
tous on évoque aujourd'hui qu'ils
étaient vraies questions sont bien
structurés aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
forcément déjà laissé d'introduire la
manière avec laquelle on à différencier
notre projet de l'existant et de dire
que par rapport à l'existant il ya
quarante ans la compagnie elle a 34 ans
et 6 ans le conception avant donc ça
fait 40 ans et c'est souvent ce qu'on
voit pas qui détermine comment les
choses tiennent en haut il y avait
vraiment une
interrogé véritablement une rupture avec
la pensée sociale d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça que le mot politique de la ville a
été inventée c'était une manière de plus
faire du social ou sens de quelque chose
qui était historiquement plutôt que
caritatif à d'autres époques hygiéniste
enfin toujours quelque chose qui était
ou moralisateur ou au moins à minimath
totalement prescripteurs et donc on
s'est dit et on a saisi l'opportunité de
l'émergence du mouvement hip hop parce
que elle portait à travers toute cette
histoire de l'afrique et des caraïbes
sur plusieurs siècles
elle portait des formes innovantes
d'émancipation notamment le rapport
interpersonnelles le rapport à la
pratique et le fait qu'ils pas que le
lait change de connaissance de soi feu
ne soit pas fait sur un mode de
domination de sa chance sur en gros
l'ignorant c'est souvent ce qui est
sous-entendu il ya plein d'erreurs dans
d'abord ce n'est pas parce qu'on sait
pas tout qu'on ignore
on s'est toujours quelque chose et puis
cette ce rapport c'est un peu la
transposition d'une forme scolaire qui a
tous ses avantages mais qui trouve ses
limites
l'idée c'était d'avoir là un espace
j'allais dire complémentaires mais là
pour le coup je dirais presque
supplémentaires qui abandonnait lui
repasse à travers le riz
des habitants et pas simplement des
jeunes ou moins jeunes en déshérence à
parenthèse je pense qu'il faut cesser
d'infantiliser les enfants sérieusement
ayant n'atteint fanti lisent les vieux
c'est vous dis donc
donc c'est sur des bases comme celle ci
qu'on est parti et il ya un moment où on
s'est rendu compte de quelque chose qui
n'est pas encore avéré aujourd'hui et on
en parle souvent alors on se connaît
depuis des années cet espace où la
pratique artistique le développement du
récit personnel et du récit commun
n'arrive pas encore à s'articuler avec
les moyens de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui la politique de la ville je
parle d'un point de vue institutionnel
parce que après dans les rapports
interpersonnels nous on sait comment
faire mais c'est des choses qui vont
devoir encore évoluer et je pense qu'on
a encore une vision de la pratique
artistique ou de la culture comme
quelque chose quelque chose de décoratif
de supplément d'âme de quelque chose qui
est pas forcément nécessaire pour des
gens qui ont besoin de trouver un boulot
enfin oui et ça je pense que c'est
encore une idée qu'il faut mettre en
débat et se rendent compte que cette
notion de récits de territoire dans
laquelle chacun trouve à être reconnu
dans laquelle chacun peut construire une
distance avec sa propre image au départ
et puis une distance une justesse avec
l'autre c'est-à-dire citoyenneté
civilisé civilise 6 bis c'est construire
de la ville et j'en profite pour dire
que si ce mot veut dire ça alors je
m'interroge parce que moi des talents il
y en a pas forcément dans les espaces
enfin il y en a pas que dans les espaces
de fortes concentrations à emmerdements
maximum d'accord il y en a absolument
partout donc c'est pour ça je me méfie
du terme talent non pas que le talent
évidemment c'est ce qui va émerger mais
ou alors disons le autrement
tout le monde a un talent tout le monde
a un talent à dire maintenant de bien
entendu d'ailleurs entendu ski
entendu ce que vous disiez jean djoman
notamment sur le fait qu' on n'est
jamais ignorants et on s'est toujours
quelque chose de travail que vous menez
que vous avez mené vous mener toujours
au sein de la compagnie black blanc beur
c'est ce qui se retrouva positif planète
en fait lorsque vous nous expliquer que
voilà il y avait eu un échec mais que
pour autant on va cet échec a appris des
choses aussi à cette personne qui va se
relancer sur autre chose il ya un
travail qui a à peu près le même qui est
menée aussi oui c'est tout à fait ça
c'est on est sur les sur les mêmes axes
mais on y est différemment en fait mais
tout va ensemble notre histoire
questionne aussi une entreprise parce
que c'est le support associatif
aujourd'hui qui historiquement est on a
tenté d'étrangler sa est réelle en
attente et si on attendait ça parce que
justement on pensait qu'il fallait qu'on
sorte de ce côté un peu dépendant un peu
caritatif à laisser décoller du social à
l'époque et je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui reste très important encore et
quand le social ou caritatifs persie
dans la politique de la ville il faut
leur père et il faut l'interroger
peut-être je dirais pas le chat c'est
parce que quand on commence à avoir des
mots négatifs comme ça on peut pas
prétendre faire du positif mais tout à
fait je pense que ce qui est commun
c'est l'idée qu'un moment donné chacun
peut être à la hauteur de sa propre
entreprise de vie et participer d'une
entreprise plus large à partir au moment
où un certain nombre de conditions sont
remplies
je pense qu'on sous estime encore très
fortement la capacité de l'art de la
pratique artistique et je pense que ce
soit dans le milieu scolaire en appui
d'un processus de recherche d'emploi ou
deux reconnaissent enfin de d'affiner la
nature de ce que font les gens de ce
qu'ils ont vraiment envie de faire de
trouver vraiment leur truc
eh bien je pense que il ya là encore et
j'ajouterais même encore autre chose là
dessus je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce type
de processus est encore ce qu'on peut
mettre de mieux en face de la
radicalisation par un dernier bon
puisqu'on arrive à la fin de cette demi
heure des démissions et et de discussion
pour 7,8 société le premier spectacle de
black blanc beur s'appelait j'en ai tout
à oui oui cela colle toujours
m'enfin on la savait depuis longtemps
j'en ai tout à quarante ans après
il reste quoi de ce message il est
toujours d'actualité
il reste rien parce que je vais vous
dire c'était pas un message moi le mot
message on l'a écarté dès le départ
peut-être même un peu violent
on a appris avec moins violent depuis
parce que l'idée c'était pas temps de
dire nous on a quelque chose à dire aux
autres l'idée c'était d'être quelque
chose c'est à dire qu'on se sente
inferno 430 ces concessions seront comme
des grands prennent des références
nouvelles prennent des questions nous on
n'amène aucune réponse
mais si on a réussi au moins à produire
à temps qui permet aux gens eux de
repartir avec des questions même une
seule une vraie question
le job est fait merci aux gens que
j'aime et merci à tous les quatre d'être
venu sur ce plateau est aussi cette
thématique
c'est la fin du set 8 sociétés pour ce
mois ci où on se retrouve bientôt sur
cette antenne pourrait changer à nouveau
sur l'actualité autour d'un nouveau
documentaire à bientôt
[Musique]